right yeah I only got one job years of
auditioning I got one sitcom job it was
like it was for a happy family and it
was a recurring character I never
remember this it comes who was it who's
in it it was like John Larroquette and
Wow Christine the bran skate yeah was it
was that three cameras single it was
three camera huh
so I go in and I my reading is I have a
very I read like a third grader just
that's what I do so I get there and
they're like oh we got some new lines
for you and it was the network
read-through oh it was like four aw dude
it was a lot to get to shore right but I
would memorize it so now they plot me
down with eight new lines when I'm a
dyslexic maniac so I stammered through
this are you dyslexic really yeah bad
and I didn't I've never like been
actually tested so I I may not be mhm
some other problem yeah areas I have to
read a line a bunch of time I don't just
read a line and move on all right we're
gonna get bunker down and figure out
what that word is and then we'll throw
the next it's a long boring thing so I
stammered through the whole thing and
then they fired me they did fire yeah
right
what were you got in your corn they
fired you they well they actually I'll a
my and I knew I was fired and then the
next day not only from coming in yeah
funny thing because there's like the
character stopped me yeah she was like
waiting for me and she said but
something really funny she goes well at
least you're going to Iraq next week I
was going to Iraq yeah to do shows to a
USO show
yeah like but that wasn't a good thing
for did going to Iraq yeah Wow anyway
that is that no one let me see something
when something because I already took me
down like I I haven't booked anything
since how long ago was that 2003 Wow I
booked sketch shows right but not any
I've never booked like a sick that's why
I don't go out probably
it's surfing crazy because it's like you
know i-i've been watching you for years
on stage yeah and I know how other
people talk about you I really do people
just think you're a list
you really are and you're a regular at
all the clubs
everyone knows you and I it just really
it baffles my mind that that's what's
happened yeah well I I mean that is
important to me and and I appreciate
that and that makes me feel like that am
i don't feel unlucky or like poor me
that I didn't get any big shows I feel
like I understand let me be honest with
you and this is that because sometimes I
lie that's why I have to keep saying
that I'm not being honest yeah because
like no I really do 90% thing I say is a
lie so when I'm saying something honest
I'm really trying to be like with no
filter yeah no this is that I think your
day is coming yeah I do I believe
wonder-percent believe that way and and
can you paint the picture of what's
coming for me well I this is what I
believe that was I'm ready for it
because I get sorry too but I know I
don't know but I'm gonna just say this
too is is that you I say that a lot as
well can I say this because people say
that along on comments they go too hard
as you keep saying that could I just say
something so I'm going to quit cut that
oh no ok just say something then is this
is how it's gonna happen mm-hm
because already now you know you all we
needed to see really people to see is
just on your Instagram just the diverse
impression of Trump your Melania and
then to see what's her name the girl the
transition Caitlyn Jenner
transy the transient yeah the transient
and just the the the it there's polar
opposites these impressions right so you
can def and their get on I believe and
so that in itself is like oh my god this
guy you know has range in that way and
also arm if that's gonna elevate you in
terms of stand up as well it's gonna
draw people yeah if you do a podcast
yeah it's gonna draw more people in this
I'm telling you right now the
we thought okay so the reason why I
think I'm doing okay right now is
because when I met her I met her on
tinder and I literally had nothing as
good as Arab air but yeah I had nothing
in my career yeah I do here's a mad I
had one other sitcom that I was on but
other than that really no auditions and
and I always compare myself to other
Asians you know so I got Ken's killing
at Randall Parks killing it I can't even
get you know the lights so uh and I met
her and I went you know this is gonna be
my path here just being a real guy you
know I want a relationship I want to
fall in love I wanna who knows if a
family's down the road but this chasing
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it doesn't really
mean anything
mmm I know it seems like it does because
of the state that we're in the society
where we social media is so like
entangled into everyone's affairs and
you get to see or a false glimpse up
into somebody's life a fake talk about
fake news mm-hmm you know it's it's
sterile it's a yeah it's right there is
specific so when you let it go and you I
just let it go
and I go it's over it's fine yeah I
still do stand-up on the road that's I'm
still making not as much I'm living you
know and I really love kalila so but she
slowly I was a puppy
what's a puppy yet she slowly got me
back in the game and it was I think her
all her and and this podcast has a lot
to do with it yeah her going because of
this podcast and because Judd Apatow was
hanging at the store mm-hmm I just he
keeps keeps running into me because we
get the time kind of close time salons
so when I got the audition for love and
I read okay
a um he just gave it to me yeah right
and then because I met this guy Dean he
was a director at LA he did they also
produced he left the show due to the
sitcom I'm doing now uh-huh
and when he goes what about Bobby for
this thing yeah like uh and then they
he's great on love okay Willie Reed and
he goes he won't read yeah they just
gave it to me so my point is is that
it's all connected in that way so I I
honestly feel like this is the beginning
for you
[Music]